c'est dans ce bar pmu du centre-ville de
crêches-sur-saône que la victime a été
vue pour la dernière fois dimanche
dernier en fin d'après midi il y fait la
connaissance d'un routiers étrangers
venus chercher de l'aide
son camion serait tombé en panne ils
repartent ensemble
carlos gordon est retrouvé inconscient
le lendemain dans le coffre de sa
mercedes sur cette voie d'accès située à
proximité de l aire d'autoroute de
crêches sur saône sur l'a61 lieu bien
connu pour être le théâtre de toutes
sortes de trafics
il porte de nombreuses traces de coups
notamment à la tête l'homme âgé de 70
ans est immédiatement transporté à
l'hôpital de mâcon et décède des suites
de ses blessures vendredi dans la
journée
le routier qui serait d'origine
portugaise et donc activement recherché
un portrait robot devrait être diffusé
l'autopsié pratiquée vendredi n'a pas
permis de déterminer si les causes de la
mort étaient criminelle ou accidentelle
les résultats des analyses
complémentaires devraient être connus
avant la fin de la semaine
l' enquête se poursuit sous la direction
du parquet de mâcon